the main reason OverWatch 2 exists is
done gone canceled not happening and
people are understandably Furious so
there was no need for OverWatch 2 it was
a cash grab marketing scam a scam
s-c-a-m at the same time the company's
not done there they are shutting down
fan projects and ruining the economy in
classic Wrath of the Lich King blizzard
can't stop catching L's OverWatch 2 is
an unmitigated disaster at this point
and the game director's priority telling
people that not all PVE was canceled
yeah I couldn't believe it either but
folks I think it's time to face facts
the blizzard you thought you knew
is gone is it over
at long last
no King rules forever my son
hey guys before we get into the video
bees okay no actually just wanted to
remind you if you're not already
subscribed to the channel it's a great
way to show your support and if you have
a good time today feel free to like the
video to let us know that too plus there
will be a b update at the end of this
video so if you want a b update
you'll have it for real
so about a week ago blizzard revealed
that the PVE plans for OverWatch 2 had
essentially been scrapped and that the
PVE that we do get whatever it looks
like will be a lot more like what we've
seen in OverWatch one instead of those
fancy hero powers that you saw it's
clear that we we can't deliver on that
original vision for PVE that was shown
in 2019. what that means is that we
won't be delivering that dedicated hero
mode with tala trees that long-term
power progression those things just
aren't in our plans anymore now maybe
some of you don't care about the PVE and
I can't say I blame you based on the
previous content that we've seen in
OverWatch but pde was kind of the reason
they gave us for having to make this
game in the first place and now we're
just not getting it okay the game's
initial release did bring some changes
to gameplay like 5v5 instead of 6v6 and
the push mode and maps that you play
that mode on and I thought they were
okay at the time but the competitive
Community has since sort of come around
on 6v6 and the way it was at least it
was something new and in OverWatch that
had been hard to come by because
OverWatch 2 had been in development for
a few years and during that time there
wasn't a lot of new stuff hitting the
game but all that development time
didn't create a whole lot of new stuff
when the game actually released which I
pointed out when I gave my Impressions
on the release of OverWatch 2. pretty
hard to review a game when it feels so
much like its predecessor but it's
doubly so when a huge portion of the
development time that went into this
title seemingly isn't represented in the
game that we're playing right now I also
said at the time that blizzard really
needs this game to succeed and here we
are again so what do we actually have
now well OverWatch 1 the buy to play
model is gone and in its place we have a
battle pass focused OverWatch 2 where
some heroes are actually locked behind
it and in his video on the topic samito
argued rightfully in my opinion that
this is basically the worst possible
model if you want the game to be able to
withstand meta shifts so right now the
big fear about having characters be
locked and competitive is what if one of
the DLC Heroes becomes hard meta kind of
like junker Queen is right now and
people certain tanks just set to sit
there and say oh sorry guys I don't have
Jungle Queen unlocked and she's is the
best hero in the game and again let's be
honest this team has had a very hard
time balancing any version of OverWatch
so it's not like this is implausible so
what seems like the Lion's Share of
development time went into something
that won't be released and likely never
will be lots of people have reacted to
this in different ways but one way is to
say that essentially OverWatch 2 has
been canceled sure it's maybe a bit
hyperbolic but I think they're way more
right than they are wrong and blizzard
only have themselves to blame for that
because they were the ones who said that
OverWatch 2 needed to exist because of
PVE OverWatch 2 will feature a ton of
content we will have a complete story
experience featuring story missions the
first of which which is called Rio de
Janeiro is also playable in Hall a for
all of you today
now it seems like they released one
third of a game and when they did that
they might have known that they weren't
going to release the other two-thirds
but they let you buy the battle pass and
some skins maybe before letting you in
on that secret so imagine you're in the
midst of one of the biggest public
disgraces for your company barring the
of course legal issues and harassment
complaints and whatnot and your fan base
is either in Revolt or in mourning so
what's your message going to be to the
community as game director of OverWatch
2. well we didn't cancel all the PVE the
only way I would write this in that
position is if my family was literally
taken hostage by Bobby Connick like hair
splitting this extreme could potentially
discover a kind of hair-based nuclear
fission like I could end up blowing up
my whole neighborhood or something I
don't know like imagine I invite you to
dinner we're gonna get chicken tandies
and waffle fries eyes from this great
place near my house if I later call you
and say hey sorry about that dinner is
canceled you would think yeah okay that
dinner is canceled but I still gotta get
some tendys somehow if I want to eat so
when people say OverWatch 2 PvE was
canceled it's pretty obvious that they
don't mean that there will never be a
piece of PVE in OverWatch 2 again it
means that our chicken tendies were
canceled you did cancel what was
promised okay like the PVE that was
promised was canceled like this is where
it's it's like that nerd Emoji you know
where you're like wow well actually it's
a guy it's like just say it for what it
is okay blizzard told us that OverWatch
2 needed to exist because of this new
amazing PVE that they were going to put
in the game and then they canceled it
but blizzard were the ones who told us
that it was the reason for OverWatch 2.
I wouldn't really call myself a fan of
Blizzard at this point but if I were I'd
ask myself why did the game director of
OverWatch 2 decide to write something
that kind of insults the intelligence of
the fans who are so upset but the hits
don't stop there and I want to preface
this by saying I was a member of this
fan Community for a very long time but
blizzard has managed to piss off the
most humiliatingly loyal fan base that
they have wow players by adding the wow
token to wow classic Wrath of the Lich
King basically this is a token that you
can use to get a month of game
subscription so you would buy it with
gold or alternatively you can give
blizzard your real dollars get a token
and sell it in game for gold the problem
is that with gold becoming viable on
demand without putting your credit card
into an extremely Shady website we're
likely to see the price of stuff go up
even if gold isn't directly being added
to the economy and well that means it's
gonna affect people who don't want to
use the token either sure if the price
of stuff goes up maybe you could
counteract that by farming some more or
but who wants to spend a few more hours
in scholazar Basin at this point there
were some Whispers a while back when
this was added to the Chinese servers
and some people said oh they won't do
that here well here it is the moderators
of the classic wow subreddit even
suspended the moratorium on discussing
privately run wow servers because
they've lost faith in blizzard so why
did blizzard do this well wow players
and the warcraft franchise are still
bringing in a lot of money for blizzard
as per their last quarterly SEC filing
at the same time let's not forget
Blizzard's partnership in China with
netease ended poorly and they have no
access to the Chinese market at this
point so to me it kind of looks like
they're just trying to monetize the
consistent part of their fan base even
more heavily it just so happens that
even wow players and again I used to be
one have a limit here Activision has
been busy too shutting down Cod fan
projects like x-labs a modded Cod client
but actually let you play older Cod
games online since it fixed
vulnerabilities within the game client
you needed the game to use the modded
client but as of May 23rd they've shut
down everything but to close I just want
to say that I really don't think there's
much hope of this getting better anytime
soon OverWatch 2 kind of feels like it's
done growing it's not going to disappear
or die instantly I mean unless blizzard
pulls a plug on that which I assume will
never happen but at the same time how
could you see it becoming an esport on
the level of Counter-Strike or even an
IP on the level of something like League
of Legends the wow classic changes in my
opinion are unlikely to cause Financial
damage to Blizzard at least in the short
term because unfortunately wow players
and again I used to be one of them will
suffer through a lot to get that
dopamine hit of a new purple item
putting the wow token in now also feels
kind of like an admission that maybe the
growth the game has plateaued at least
for the moment and that if they add it
while some people will leave it will be
financially worth it to get it in the
game now plus the ultimate tier of this
expansion is of course icecrown Citadel
that's not out yet so you got to get the
Wow token in the game before that but
you don't want to do it when you launch
the best rate in the expansion you hope
that people will kind of forget about it
when they come back to do it right wow
players I get it I've been there Chris
Benson still loves you
peace and love Final Fantasy 14 has a
great free trial one of the last reason
that I think that we're not going to see
a blizzard bounce back anytime soon is
just that the Staffing situation seems
to be pretty dire we've got people that
are openly speaking against the
company's return to office policy but in
addition to that it kind of seems like
they're having trouble finding new
people maybe Diablo 4 will still be good
maybe not people seem to enjoy the tests
but at the same time reports have
alleged that they are burning through
Talent both from Crunch and attrition
other teams have members who publicly
said similar things about their ability
to staff if these reports are true it
might be possible to launch a good
Diablo 4 but will it be possible to
support it and if Diablo 4 trips at the
starting line what does blizzard even
have left so I offer a final Point here
the blizzard that you thought you knew
if you knew them before the words
Activision Blizzard went together all
the time is gone and it's not coming
back probably never coming back because
as things stand it seems like leadership
changes have to happen before any of
these issues will improve and none of
that is a given and I think it's best
that we all just admit that maybe that
makes you sad maybe that makes you like
weirdly gleeful for some reason but as
Garrosh Hellscream once said in an
alternate timeline times change
yeah no that's it's funny also be update
B update this is probably the actual end
board because we need a b update I'm
gonna go with Bob Bela
um great name we're gonna show I'll find
the comment we'll show it on screen
who commented Bob Fila and the reason is
of course Bob Vila This Old House and
the number one reason I know this
is I was trying to get on the Super
Nintendo when I was a kid and my dad was
probably watching Bob Vila I was trying
to play like luffia or something and he
was like no I can't it's the only time
it's on Josh I'm not taping it okay cool